directly into the open discussion the
open discussion is motive so any
questions you want to ask about this
talks or anything before good we
continue
now thank you uh thank
you so one of the goals of this Workshop
is to draw connections between Theory
application and systems and we will We
Have Heard more theoretical talks in the
last uh uh uh yesterday and today I am
going to tell you about an application
and we will hear other talks in the uh
rest of the workshop so these talk is
about an application of first order
logic to database education so quick PLL
uh how many of you have ever taught a
database course or have been a TA of a
database course oh wow
okay
lasted so then you know that uh CS
enrollment is increasing so these are
some statistics from duke computer
science and uh so is the enrollment in
database courses like we added some
prerequisite it dropped a little and
then it again uh went up to more than
300 uh from uh just 50 students 10 years
ago so how do we provide students or TS
automated personalized help to dearies
okay H here is an example uh this is a
database that many of you are familiar
with this this is the beers database we
have uh drinkers frequent uh bars
Drinker like Drinker likes beer and bar
uh serves beer we don't need to really
need this database uh in this stock so
suppose you as an instructor uh have
given this question that find the a bar
serving a beer at the highest price but
the student returns that not at the
lowest price so your query is non
monotone it requires a minus student
query is monotone now uh how do you
convince the student as a TA or as an
instructor that where their query uh
went wrong and uh these queries both the
questions and the answers can get quite
complicated so this is a a slide from
dance uh lecture notes and you can see
that fine drinkers that frequent only
bir that serve some we they like only
some flipped and so on and if you find
your name here that that doesn't mean
anything okay uh okay so uh this queries
get complicated so the broad goal of uh
this project that we have been working
on for a while is to build tools to help
students debar quaries okay without
revealing the solution of course so uh
how about an autog grader so uh like gr
scope we do use autograder so we have
like a very carefully crafted database
that my colleague uh uh Jun Yang um um
uh have uh has built for several years
so you have the correct query and you
have a wrong query and then this is a
teste database instance and the
autograder checks if um uh these two
queries uh are the same on this
particular database okay so this is not
query
equivalence now uh that is okay uh but
not quite because the test instance can
be very big and it doesn't pinpoint the
source of eror uh in students
query then we had a prior work this is
uh just to motivate the pro uh this our
our solution here that uh we have this
big database instance that
differentiates the correct query and the
wrong query how do we find the smallest
sub instance that would still
differentiate these two queries now you
can perhaps quickly uh see that this is
easy if Q2 is monoton but it is NP hard
in general um you you can show that and
what we did here that we used uh Boolean
how provenance um uh that we have been
discussing uh in this program and also
in this uh uh Workshop that to uh find
the difference between the answer of q1
and Q2 and then we are trying to find a
solution that would make this bully on
how provenance uh true with minimum
number of ones so of course this is NP
heart so we are using NP Sol SM smt
solvers and multiple optimizations we
have extension to Aggregates uh so this
is um uh this was like that was the
technical contribution um uh
contribution to database education is
that um JJ uh built a tool with a UI and
uh this has been used for the last five
years at Duke by more than 1600 students
now because we keep track of how many
students for our NSF reports uh so this
has been a very highly uh useful tool
for debugging relational algebra queries
and uh as you can see like for this
highest versus non lowest it returns a
concrete ground instance uh showing
three distinct values and if these three
values are present then highest is going
to return only one answer but not lowest
is going to return return two answerers
so this uh shows the difference and uh
we had a very detailed uh user
study uh in in the class in Fall 2017 um
and then students where we can skip this
now but you if you quickly read this you
can see that the students were most very
um uh supportive and optimistic and uh
about this tool but they also pointed
out some drawbacks like it would have
been very nice if you if it had more
instances because one instance is not
enough to find all the edits and add a
little more context like where did I go
wrong and so on so these are these these
were the feedback from the students so
that motivated our uh next work that can
we specify the source of it using an
obstruction uh instead of a concrete or
ground instance okay so this is the work
that I'm going to talk about uh in the
rest of the time and this is a joint
work with uh Amir gilad who is now at
Hebrew University of Jerusalem Jen J Meo
now at Simon friser University and my
colleague at Duke uh
junior okay so here are our two queries
so this is the question again little
modified that that for each beer liked
by Drinker whose first name is Eve so
you can see in the correct query there
is a little space there find the bar
serving the beard at the highest price
okay so this is the correct query and
the wrong query uh it Returns the non
lowest and it makes another mistake like
it uh misses the space here uh this is a
ground instance yes when you when you
say correct quy or wrong quy you mean
the so the set of data that they give
back or because not efficient how is Bri
them uh not correct correct semantic
wise not not efficiency wise we are not
not not looking at the like it can be
arbitrarily
complex so this is a solution written by
our previous work that it would show a
concrete ground instance showing three
distinct
prices but where did this go wrong that
we want to show something like this that
Q2 Returns the bar serving the beard at
the price uh in the middle if there are
three bars with uh if uh with different
prices okay so we want a condition like
that and uh we also want to find out all
the erors like first name is if Q2 also
returns wrong result if the drinker's
first name starts with if but is not
exactly uh now uh H how do we do that
how do we get such abstract ction as a
solution so this is what we proposed
this is inspired by C tables this is
like a slight modification of cables
proposed by imilan Sky and lipy for uh
incomplete databases this is a
conditional instance so instead of
actual values what we have here uh are
variables like X1 B1 and so on if if
something does not matter there we have
star and we have a global condition here
so the global condition here says that
if there are this these three distinct
prices then this conditional instance
will differentiate the correct query and
the wrong query note that we do not have
a gr uh uh we are not starting with a
database now like we are differentiating
two queries
okay uh and then not just one instance
we want to return a set of conditional
instances this is another conditional
instance that is showing that if you're
if you return uh a name that starts with
if but is not exactly like first name is
not if then also your query uh will go
wrong in if if you have a um uh database
instance like that so how do we get such
conditional instance uh what we are
doing we are not directly working with
SQL we are converting that to domain
relational calculus and this is a query
tree of uh this particular wrong query
so when we have two queries one correct
query and one wrong query we are looking
at the difference of Q2 minus q1 that is
Q2 and not q1 okay you could do the
other way too so this is the query tree
for Q2 minus
q1 now for Q2 minus q1 or in general for
any Q we want to characterize different
ways Q is satisfied uh that is it
returns non-empty uh results so what are
the applications of course like you can
use it in a classroom you can explain
why queries are different you can
explore how various parts of the query
can be triggered by different data you
can use it to build your uh test switch
like the uh to construct that test
instance to use in your
autograder so what is a good
characterization for Q what solution do
we want we want the basic requirements
that is the global uh we want that for
each conditional instance that we are
returning it should be consistent that
is the global condition should be
satisfiable uh in that conditional
instance it's it should be sound that is
the query should be satisfiable by that
uh conditional instance and of course
minimality like we want we don't want
redundant topls or redundant condition
uh in the solution moreover we ideally
want completeness now what does
completeness mean so you you can you can
want obvious notion of completeness
would be take any ground instance that
satisfies the query and there should be
a mapping a homomorphism from your
conditional instance to that ground
instance which does not work because
there could be unbounded size for the
all these ground instances so we are
using a notion of coverage to uh Define
our completeness uh defining
completeness was quite non-trivial in
this work and no redundancy that we want
to return a set such that like no one
can be removed from that
Set uh so uh how do we get to this
solution we we are enumerating
homomorphisms from query variable to
level none uh in the C instance let's
see a quick example for the soundness
that these are the free variables these
are the query tree um and then we are
looking at all this different mapping
and then eventually uh what we are
getting that uh this uh uh query tree uh
this conditional instance does not
satisfy this query tree but for another
mapping this is now satisfied so this
could be a solution okay we will I will
walk through a very short example uh
later how about the completeness the
notion of completeness was motivated by
code coverage that we want to know that
this different part this does not mean
anything for our work but we want to
make sure that this different part of
this conjunction and disjunction they
are covered by these different
conditional instances that we are
returning uh so this is the notion that
we are checking whether a conditional
instance would cover all these ground uh
atoms of our query tree so this
conditional instance uh covers many of
these except two so this is one of our
solution and then if we add another one
then some of the remaining ones are also
common so we want a set of conditional
instances that would cover all our uh uh
leaps H so this is finally our problem
definition that given uh domain
relational calculus quq find the set of
conditional instances such that these uh
instances are sound they are minimal not
redundant and also complete ideally okay
this is
ideally now probably so far like you
have already figured out that this Sol
this uh problem is undecidable because
this is uh even existence of this
solution is undecidable for uh General
DRC queries uh because uh from finite
model satisfiability of first toal logic
Tren br's theorem so we cannot get an
exact solution to this problem but that
does not mean that we can get a huris
stic so what we are doing we are running
a Chase inspired procedure to build
these conditional instances we are
enumerating these all these
homomorphisms from query variables uh to
the labeled nulls uh in the C instances
and then we are post-processing for
satisfiability and redundancy using smt
solvers once again
yes so I'm trying to understand what
language you so you said domain Rel so
you have these like filters like like
and then last time you could yeah so we
have all those like the uh Atomic
predicates we are we are allowing like
yes so no Aggregates no Aggregates yeah
no yes so as long as the SQL can be
converted to domain relational calculus
with these conditions then it is fine
yeah yes ma'am so I understand why you
need theistic stoping condition but I'm
also worried that if you consider
general for the logic Expressions it's
so clear what the chase means let let me
let me show you yeah so this is this is
not complete okay we no guarantee on the
completeness because because of the
stopping condition and also because of
like when you have any universal
quantifier so we are we are trying to
get a solution that covers like um you
can have a stopping condition on time
you can have a stopping condition on
number of variables you are adding to
the conditional instance and if you are
yes yeah is are the labeled nouns
invented by this CH yes yes they are
they are they are built from scratch
from empty conditional
instance okay so let me do a very simple
walk through so you have a very simple
query here find drinkers who either like
Biser or do not like any beer okay so we
have a for all and four all is the
source of all um U
complexities so if we have this or at
the top so this is a recursive algorithm
we are building all the set of
conditional instances one by one uh if
we have or we are reducing it to these
three conjunctive trees uh like the both
branches are true or one branch is true
and the other branch is not let's
proceed with the middle one here
uh this is the simpler simple one so
this one has conjunction and they are
exist so you uh uh you consider like all
branches you start with an empty mapping
so I am keeping track of the domains of
all these variables that are there and
also I'm keeping track of the
homomorphisms okay so mapping from the
query variable to our C instance
variables so first uh I have D for
drinker so I have I am introducing a new
variable D1 here domain of B beer that
is already given so this is B visor and
my first homomorphism is D2
D1 then uh so I have a simple
conditional instance here like only one
to pull D1 and B Weiser in the likes
then I'm checking whether this satisfies
uh the query uh so this one could be
empty so uh uh sorry I will check all
all the uh mappings from for this new
variable B so it could come from the
existing existing domain or it could be
a new level null so here if you map this
beer to this existing value B visor then
this is true that like and D1 B viser is
already in the C instance so this
evaluates to true now I will check a new
um so this is this is this is the
homomorphism for this conditional
instance okay so I got our first
conditional instance how about the next
one then this the exist B could be a new
beer B1 so I will check with that again
uh proceed here I will add a new likes
stle D1 B1 and then check that yeah this
this also satisfies the query so I got
another another conditional instance
okay so I I could either have one lik
stle or I could have two lik truls
here for um uh the first one when we
have this four all uh that is the tricky
one because now different branches could
have different mappings so what we do
that we take all of them um and Marge
all the results and uh uh so so
especially like if you have a
disjunction below for all then it gets
real complex like you can see that uh
for all PX or QX you cannot do that
trick like it will miss some solutions
that if you check both are true or one
is true excuse me as you the query is
not
safe because of the universal
modification you need to say something
if B is a beer you did it in when you
domain has written is not something so
uh I think like this is this this was
like one of the uh uh roadblocks that
how do we Define this safety when we are
uh doing all this Chase to construct the
solution I think this what uh in the
original word we have U
uh you you are right like sorry this uh
um uh wait what we are doing like we are
doing a mapping and then we are
proceding but the safety was
like yes will be from some other from
the active domain of some other exactly
so this is this is like the partial tree
so this is this is uh this is some
bindings are coming from the top uh that
like you are building homomorphism like
you you have already you already have
some mapping and then you are extending
for the
subtr but but you are right so like when
uh this the safety for this problem that
was one of the like how do we how do we
have this binding before we proceed that
was one of the bottle leg so this uh so
what I'm hiding here this exact notion
of coverage and mapping so this is this
was this was quite complex like going
through the ground instance and then
mapping back them to the uh condition
instances and then we had some other
optimizations for this complex cases for
all uh and Then followed by a
disjunction okay so um I I will just
show you uh that in in this project we
frequently do user studies uh in
consultation with IRB and what here we
had uh we had a pilot study with the uh
some graduate and graduate students so
we gave them to spot ERS in two SQL
queries uh QA and QB uh each has two
errors so um when you work with students
and when you need feedback from students
you cannot do a control study like a
fully randomized control study you
cannot give half of the student one
query and the other half the other query
so what we did we randomized with the
query like half of the student got QA as
the treatment and QB as the control and
the other half got QA as the control and
QB as the treatment uh and then we
showed them the concrete values the
ground instances from our previous work
and these abstract instances so um the
result was sort of mixed that we saw
that um ground instances they were more
comfortable in some sense like this
meaning of this conditional instances
that took them some time to understand
like what it means but otherwise this
when uh this when we showed the a set of
conditional instances that help them
find multiple erors which one ground
instance could not help them find so
this has promise and we have to figure
out like how to make it like more
understandable uh to students in a more
natural language for
um so um summary this uh database
education and automated ta uh is an
important and potentially high impact
area of research it uses database Theory
database systems uh optimization user
interface user study uh several groups
are working on this WF gang is working
on the some similar similar like this
database how to help students understand
the meaning of database queries and also
groups from Georgia Tech and uh
Singapore like many groups are working
like in this
direction um what we did in this work is
query characterization by conditional
instances uh advantages is that it is
test instance independent we are we are
expressing the difference between two
queries q1 and Q2 and we are capturing
different ways to satisfy a query so uh
as a result this is undecidable problem
but in any case we are uh giving a
solution using Chase and then we are
doing this detailed user study to help
users especially students spot the error
we are collaborating with our colleagues
in uh Computer Science Education and we
have several other work in this project
uh um with debuger treaser for SQL which
is much more complex than relational
algebra or relational calculus and how
to uh generate hints to fix a query so
this is the project web page like these
tools are all available online and if
you if you want to give them a try just
let me know and I can uh share them with
you um and there are several open
questions that these conditional
instances this does not work for
Aggregates or if you have a having
clause in the previous work for ground
instance we use the work by Val and
Daniel and Y on this Provence suing for
Aggregates uh uh for um uh handling
Aggregates and having but for
conditional instances we do not know how
to approach there so this is something
uh to study uh there are what would be
other decidable forms of explanation
like you as an instructor or teaching
assistant what form of explanation you
would like to give students and can we
capture that can we formalize that and
can we have automated solutions to get
to that okay so of course we want
explanations in natural language and um
big questions in this work is how to use
or get around llms uh that because you
can like students can ask the llm uh
that how is highest different from non
lowest and they will probably get a good
answer there okay so um I I guess that's
it and uh happy to take more questions
thank
[Applause]
you L of
fun
so I want um I wonder if uh the way
there might be an alternative way to
handle the universal
quantifiers
using Duality that is so so think so the
chase is a is a procedure that kind of
saturates a qu or an instance right um
but those are
existential most this queries right so
if you have a un
quy is it have you EX at all um
speculated about saturated the negation
of that way which now would be an
existential so I'm I'm blissfully
ignorant of of of safy sorry are are you
are you thinking of the non answers here
or also for yeah well so so what you
want is to construct these uh these
instance
right so if you instead of taking just
simply a positive approach of what the
instance is that is how you can add
these label t with label vals and
so um it would of course mean expanding
your your uh entire understanding of the
database to also talk
about uh the non ansers that is the Tob
which are not in the database and how
the fact that they are not in the
database affect the truth of the
query and it's possible that you can
kind of you know f with with a Chase for
the negation and saturate with negative
facts so you would work with two
instances one is the instance of the tup
in the database one is the instance of
the tup not in the datab yes uh what I
find interesting is though that you add
the the this still number allows you to
talk about labeled nulls and therefore
allows you to go at least in these in in
these
uh examples allows you to go beyond the
active domain yes which I think is is
there is no active domain I don't yeah
so that's so there may be I I think I
think that will be that will be
interesting um a quarter bit
suggestion I think we need to explore
ideas like that that when we have uh can
how do we do this missing missing values
yeah that that is a good direction
B your question about Aggregates does
this include the group ey clause also or
you
just so for group buy you could uh if
you have group buy that is you can
ignore that because you can just do T by
T so like you can you can look at the
like why one particular tupol appears in
the answer of Q2 and the not in the
answer of q1 so uh but it is basically
the same thing so the group by is like
but having is a more uh like fundamental
uh what about questions for for
discussion in a moment to set up and
then
I